- We're here on Hollywood Boulevard
and we're gonna figure out
exactly how much people know
about this week's pop culture.
(record scratching)
(pop music)
Question number one.
Who swapped out their unicorn wig
for their Good Morning America
appearance earlier this week?
- I have no idea.
(buzzer)
- Katie Perry? (laughs)
- Chyna and Rob.
(bell dings)
- That would be Blac Chyna.
- Uh, Caitlyn Jennings?
(buzzer)
- No, no. It's Blac Chyna.
Blac Chyna was dating Rob Kardashian.
They had a big falling out.
- That's right! That happened.
- Yeah.
What would you say to Rob Kardashian?
- Man up.
- Yeah, I ...
- He broke the man code.
You don't, you don't, you don't.
- Which classic Nickelodeon cartoon
is getting a brand new movie this fall?
- Power Rangers.
(buzzer)
- No, no, no. It's a cartoon.
- Oh, a cartoon?
- SpongeBob?
(buzzer)
- (mumbles) I know what
he's talking about.
I know exactly
what he's talking about, umm.
(buzzer)
- Rugrats.
- Can I say rugrats?
- A'ight. You can say Rugrats.
That's not the right answer.
(buzzer)
It's actually "Hey Arnold!"
- [Girl With Blue Cap]
But dude, "Hey Arnold!"?
Let's go.
- I threw that out to the universe
'cause I want the Rugrats to make a movie.
- You want the Rugrats to do a new movie?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Which celebrity baby released
their first rap last week?
- DJ Khaled's son.
I don't remember his name.
Asahd?
(buzzer)
- I think Lil Wayne's
daughter's doin' something.
(buzzer)
- Jay Z?
- Yeah! That's her dad, so who's the baby?
- Blue Ivy.
(bell dings)
- Yeah, Blue Ivy when she was ...
- You've got to be kidding me.
(laughter)
- It was like, "Boom shaka
laka, boom shaka laka, boom."
- She got bars?
- Yeah! Bars for days.
- So we have a couple of questions
and these are like throwbacks.
So think back to 2007.
What song was holding on
to the number one spot,
and the title of "Song of the Summer",
on the Billboard charts
10 years ago today?
- 10 years ago?
- 10 years ago.
- I mean, I would say Beyonce.
(buzzer)
I'd be thinking, maybe Rhianna?
(bell dings)
- Good Girl Gone Bad?
(buzzer)
(bell dings)
- With Jay Z, "umbrella?
- Oh, Rhianna?
(bell dings)
- Yeah.
- Aye.
- It was Rhianna's "Umbrella".
It was on the number one
charts for seven weeks.
- This song was bumpin'.
- Kudos, kudos, kudos.
(laughter)
- Yes, you know your pop culture.
- Yeah, I'm not thinkin' 'bout.
I'm not thinkin' 'bout
Rhianna. - I'm with it.
She used to date Drake.
(buzzer)
Currently dating a billionaire.
It's like ... (laughs)
- Yes, I know about pop culture. (laughs)
And she has a new song now
called, "Wild Thoughts".
(buzzer)
(light playful music)